i i think there's a whole bunch of black
rock corporate executives or dark suits
sitting with literal strings on biden
and pulling him every step of the way as
he moves but that's just my own
perspective and opinion but i also
wanted to add i i think this concept of
of of civil unrest of a civil war it's
not a crazy one newsweek had a very
important article today and they were
talking about how civil unrest
historically is the norm after pandemics
and they talked to two political
scientists and they said between 1300
between the 1300s black death and the
1918 spanish flu there were 57 pandemics
and there was only four cases of them
that didn't result in a revolt or
large-scale protest afterwards and they
actually announced a number of times
yeah the cops just walked in yeah i
don't know what's going on here
uh
should we uh yeah that
i was looking at my notes i was like
somebody did somebody swatch you yep
somebody swatted us did they rely on us
yep somebody swatted us how do you know
how do you know i have somebody texting
me
oh okay
so
yeah just a police officer entered here
looked around because it looks like
someone swatted this live broadcast here
they're coming here busting man
yeah i mean
that's that's something that's extremely
dangerous extremely reckless
because you know swat incidences have
led to a lot of innocent people dying
uh dogs being shot people being shot
people thinking that their house is
being raided by criminals defending
themselves so
whoever did that and they're listening
like
yeah those things those things you know
and and it's a it's a healthy a healthy
penalty if you get caught swatting
that's a felony crime and you can spend
years in jail over because
the inherent risk if a police officer
you know believes that that's why it's
confirmed if if the police officer
believes that there's who knows what
they said you know they could have said
somebody is screaming or kidnapped
someone's kidnapped here we need to send
it just say and i heard a boom i heard a
boom i don't know that door allowed they
hit so what if we were in here you know
and we saw him and we pulled the trigger
on him yeah we're in the shootout with
the police you can get them hurt we can
get hurt you know it's crazy did that
happen all right let's let's let's let's
uh no we
never got caught i'm gonna i'm gonna
tell you guys what just happened
uh i just walked out of the room the
cops walked in they walked around with
flashlights we've been swatted i am
extremely unhappy with this because
i can't necessarily be mad at the
officers they were very polite but i do
not like cops coming into my house when
we have mats all over the place they
come back with the warrant yeah
and
i don't know who let them in or why what
happened uh i understand they're here
because we got swatted a report was made
that two people had been shot and killed
and that the gunman was threatening to
to hurt themselves
they didn't send a swat team it was just
a couple of officers i want to drag them
or be mean to them because
they're polite
but i'm not happy with the idea that
they're walking into our studio while we
are live they're walking around
cop immediately i walked out of the room
he immediately come upside i'm really
really sorry about this we're not trying
to you know screw with you or or ruin
what you're doing here's what happened
we got a call two people had been shot
and killed and a person was going to be
killing themselves we have to check it
out make sure everything's okay we're
going to be doing a sweep once we figure
it out and i'm just like
we're back with a warrant but i have to
say this is what i have to say i don't
think that they believe
that that was 100 true there's no way on
planet earth that only two officers
would show up to a shooting double
homicide without a barricaded subject
yeah tell them to leave and like well
then let me let me just explain this
from a police perspective as well is
that if the police do a swatting call
right
um and it's found to be illegitimate
right they you know any
evidence that they think they may have
or they mean is suppressed because this
was an illegitimate entry into a house
you can enter under exigent
circumstances but if it's an
illegitimate exigent circumstance
there's no
uh searching for evidence and different
things like that so i get it but as a
cop
i see how you can't just not do anything
what's the exergenic circumstance
accident actually
circumstances meaning that it's a
circumstance in which you have to do it
in a hurry it's a right now thing that
means that right now i have to act
emergency it's an emergency i think this
to me is like shows highlights the value
of local police because when i was in
chile i noticed it was all national cops
everywhere they all have like uniforms
standing on the corner if you get a call
like this yeah it's only national cops
you got no right no one's gonna be there
like what's happening right now you know
your neighbors what's happening right
now it doesn't make sense like if if i'm
a cop and i'm hearing active shooting
guy with a gun shot two people i'm not
gonna walk in here without a swat team
right yeah well no it depends right you
gotta think of like i said extra
circumstances
police officers have a duty to respond
immediately right a swat team takes a
while to assemble i was on the swat team
and we had about an hour
if it was a full call out a hostage
situation we still had to have enough
time for everybody on the team to get
their equipment and get to the location
and we had to get together to a certain
degree to to try to figure out what
tactics we're going to use so
it takes time if there was a real call
of two people shot a man with a gun they
have to respond now right and if those
two officers are the only ones in the
area they have to come now
and they have to force entry and they
have to make sure everything's okay that
that speaks to the bravery of law
enforcement officers because what if
there was a situation like that and they
were the only two here and they were
going to risk their lives potentially
getting mowed down
shot and killed ambushed right but they
had to respond anyway because there were
there was potential loss of life that
they had to rescue i've been here lately
the cops don't have to respond well the
supreme court has ruled many times if a
police officer sees a crime happening
they do not have to intervene that's an
argument that's an argument that's an
argument in the supreme court that's not
an argument that happens on the scene i
got news oh what's the news they entered
in uh in direct
okay hold on i was just running around
when they came to the door they were
told you may not enter without a warrant
they said we're entering anyway oh wow
which is which is lawful exigent
circumstances right we can enter your
property and search the premises right
which is what i say i told them
with respect officers
i would like you to leave
unless you have a warrant and they said
we get it we get it
we swept the house we're leaving
but that's i don't trust it no but
that's the way no no this isn't here
this is the way it's supposed to happen
right and you're right by saying hey are
you you guys done you need to leave the
police officers have to check
because if they show up here and there's
a dead body in the room somewhere
because somebody just say if somebody in
the house called and said and called it
in but they actually you know did
something to themselves and the cops
just showed up and said oh there's
nothing there
the next morning there's a dead person
in the house who's going to be held
liable so a quick sweep is reasonable
and then they have to leave for future
reference yes
cops ever walk in like that put on the
room cam okay nice well it takes me a
minute to switch it over but for sure
yeah or whatever camera shows them
brandon was talking and the cops are
like walking around flashlights and i'm
like i saw all their faces too everyone
looked though yeah
look at that the one copy like waves
over to me and i'm like no i'm like
recording
i thought he was coming to the show
because i saw the door but i'm like
who's coming in during the park
well i feel bad
they were being being nice
and i understand like someone calls in
and says people are dead yeah and
they're like let's go check it out and
their their their mentality is like
we're going to be protecting tim and his
house and everything with our lives and
we don't know what's happening if you
see it was only with two of them there
were three there were no they were like
four or four or five years because that
was the upstairs guys but when you
brought up like there's no way they
wouldn't come with gear they wouldn't be
prepared i think when they got here and
realized everything was looking normal
they were like okay
let's just do a check but it seems like
a swatting right the problem i have with
it is
i don't want to blame the guy
because there's a circumstance of you
know what if someone got killed what if
they're really in trouble but then the
problem is what if they can just use
exigent circumstances as a pretext to
come into my house we have we have
doormats at every door that's come back
with a warrant that's not a joke so uh
allison who uh
was downstairs they come to the door and
says you cannot come in without a
warrant and they said we are coming in
anyway we have oxygen circumstances and
then i was like because when they walked
in here i'm like who let them in
yeah of course first they let themselves
in
yeah and but you gotta you gotta
understand too is that you know they
can't they can't come here and do a
search you know say they supposed to be
searching for uh dead bodies yeah and a
crime they come in there's no crime they
leave so they can't go snooping around
they can't go looking in the rooms
certainly they can't actually
circumstance they will have to have to
articulate that i went and i went to
this room this room i saw the guy had a
body worn camera they can only go here
here here and leave um they can't go
snooping around your property what if
they see something illegal when they
walk around
well this is the thing like if this was
a real call and there was a real
incident that occurred and they had to
come in the house and they saw a bale of
drugs here
they have that that's that's in plain
sight they can actually
uh
come here and and get the drugs and
charge somebody with it what if it's an
exigent call and they see it's the same
thing it's in plain view that's why i'm
calling bs how well we don't do anything
like that here yeah but however if it's
a swatting
none of that i don't think any of that
will hold up in the court of law if it's
a fake call to somebody's house and the
police were here and then they see
something i don't think it would hold up
in court are they going hard on this guy
that swatted
yeah that's a bit that's a felony crime
you can do like 20 years in prison for
swatting it's a it's a it's a very
serious crime i don't i don't look men i
said it was 2022.
i'm like they are going to be going hard
against everybody you're going to be
harassed you're going to be censored
you're going to be smeared
it's but i don't think i don't think the
cops were involved i think somebody
exactly no i'm saying whoever swatted us
like
that's the pressure they wanna they
wanna put in the house but imagine like
what you were saying
there's a lot of people what's that book
you commit three felonies a day or
whatever yeah so there you know maybe
someone here did something dumb and then
we get swatted and the cops walk in
they're like oh look the cat's doing a
backflip on sunday that's illegal and
things like that and they can't do that
that's another thing are our phone calls
exit into circumstances could they be
ruled out just because someone called
and said something yeah it just depends
man like like when i was a police
officer we used to have these uh 911
hang-ups yeah and those are the most
dangerous calls because you don't know
why a person hung up if you get enough
information and it's reasonable
reasonable to believe that there could
be something there you have to check
because you may get here and two people
shot and killed in a house and a person
barricading themselves is not going to
make any noise right
and this house is confusing you know so
you know you know somebody can be
somewhere and you know i know i'll tell
you for people who don't know this house
is a maze it's like i don't know where
i'm at it's not easier than it was
before it's not the craziest but it's
funny how people get lost here and i
don't realize i'm like wow they got lost
i've been here before and i don't know
where i'm at yeah yeah cause there's
there's two different studio rooms
there's like five floors it's a
ridiculous building there's a sub
basement a basement a first second third
floor we have a new attic and uh when
you're going up to the studio there's
actually
like a fork in the road and people
usually go the wrong way and end up in
the wrong room yeah and then they get
confused it's too dark and they're like
where's the light
but that's good for me because i was
thinking about if someone broke in here
i was like well you know when we're
going over our plan for our security
protocols because we've we've had these
these threats before and i was as i was
going through it i was like wow i just
realized
a person who comes in this house will
get lost yes
what people need to understand is
there's a lot of people who are like
teams go to join a million-dollar
mansion it's an office building like the
second floor is a bunch of desks and
computers for editing work one of the
bedrooms
it's an equipment room with shelves and
a computer and then there's an editing
bay there's actual and then a music
studio this is a place where people work
not a place where people live right
right so that you're walking into a 10
000 square foot office building in the
shape of a house basically right yeah
and here's here's the silver lining in
this now the police officers know who
you are
hopefully you have a conversation with
them they know what you do for a living
and now if they get another call they
like okay slow down let me call yes
because you can give them your phone
number they'll call you and say hey we
got a call are you is everything okay
there you're like yeah they you know
it's no big deal another thing i think
would be good is to put cameras in here
so you can see what's going on well we
we do
so here can you switch can you switch to
the room cam real quick yeah hold on let
me change it so we've actually we we've
got a ptz camera that can
basically sweep the whole room uh it's
it's actually pretty good look at this
so that's why we didn't i wish we had it
ready to go well no i think i think if
we knew like no one expected cops to
walk into the studio but for future
reference we see someone let's get the
camera on i have to say they did a
pretty decent job man they nobody pulled
nobody pulled a gun
yeah you know when i was a cop and we
searched houses we had our guns out
and we were you know it was pretty it
was way more intense than that but maybe
they caught on to say oh there's
nothing going on here well we're in the
middle of nowhere yeah so when you're in
a city and you're in a house with 50
houses and hundreds of people
those cops are probably like if this
person's armed they could hurt their
neighbors
we're out in the middle of nowhere
literally like it's just trees
everywhere the cops here are probably
like well if they are locked in their
house ain't going anywhere there's
nobody around them so we'll we'll get
there as fast as we can and we'll check
it out it's it's less of a dire
circumstance as opposed to being a dense
population yeah somebody must have
called as if they were in the house
because that's what he said there's
because if it's an external person that
don't have current information in the
house
it's not safe for cops to just bombard
in it's better for them to make
announcements and hostages negotiate and
stuff like that but unless somebody's
bleeding out and then you got that whole
thing but whoever did it wanted it to
happen during the show wanted attention
too that's what they always did to send
the message obviously but his name is
and they're and they're probably
watching going like haha we did it but
they didn't do anything and if they get
found they're going to go to prison
fulfilling the crime i have a feeling
that they won't be found that's just my
personal perspective but sorry it's so
easy to spoof it's like
they might they might yeah you never
know with technology the way the
technology is today they got well the
nsa knows everything but they don't
share everything unless it works on
their personal benefit right plus it's
january 6th i'm like who knows
what what lies what manipulations but
i'm i'm just saying
2022 men the censorship the smears the
swatting the fear tactics
the establishment does not want and i
i'll say i keep telling people vote in
the primaries oh you have to local and
in the primary that is the scariest
thing because that's their secret the
republicans and the democrats know that
their worst case scenario for the most
part is even if they vote for the other
the other you know party
we we're we're winning the primaries and
the establishment will still be in power
so when we come out on our shows your
show our show whatever show we say vote
in the primaries they're like oh that's
the secret that's where you actually can
get rid of the neocons and the neolibers
that's where it change over you don't
have to wait four years you can get them
in the primary and make sure you vote
local
you know we a lot of people are are so
worried about these federal elections
that they are
the leftists are taking over
in local elections they're taking over
the school board they're taking over all
of these local elections city council
and they're running the city from within
you may have a republican senator but
the state level politicians are all
democrats and so then when election time
comes around and things like that who's
monitoring that it's going to be the
people that's on a state level and so i
think that we need to vote
in and out of season like you have to
vote you have to get involved you have
to be a part of the process you know me
and my wife we made it a promise this
year that we're going to be more a part
of the process we can't just sit back
and just talk
we got to be we got to know what's going
on we got to endorse the right
candidates we have to support candidates
fund them if we can we have to be active
or we're going to get steamrolled just
really quick because a lot of people are
asking in the comment section everyone's
fine everyone's safe i'm talking to
people on the house on the phone every
animal's safe nothing happened luckily
we were able to avoid anyone getting
seriously hurt um so we were very lucky
and everyone's okay and everyone's safe
but i was i was you know after you
mentioned like why would they just come
two guys i was like i need to go tell
them to get out like because they were
they were when i when i talked to them
they're like we're we're going to go or
whatever and then i thought no i need to
i need to see them at the door i need to
make sure that i say to them i don't
want them here i don't approve of them
being here i don't approve of any
searches
and they didn't do any extensive kind of
searching they just walked through the
house and walked out and then when i
went down i was like who let them in and
they every people were like no actually
we denied them entry and so i'm like all
right you know i think we did the best
we could do in the circumstances kind of
feels like an inoculation uh like
they're like okay we know tim they know
us that some of the cops watched the
show in the i said that uh i've been
told andreas told me once that one of
the cops he met a cop and he's like yeah
i watched the show it's awesome i think
i think they're familiar yeah they know
that they that there's going to be
efforts this is the challenge this is
the challenge with cops i feel i feel uh
i empathize with them especially if
they're keeping us safe in the event
some like some lunatic could actually
come here and then make that phone call
and they're gonna be like what if it
literally is some crazy psychopath wants
to go and and and screw up the show and
hurt people right we need their help we
do yeah so the one time they do come in
i don't want to be the boy who cried
wolf next time something bad happens i'm
like guys no for real this is me and
this is happening they're gonna be like
yeah yeah yeah yeah we're not falling
for that again and you don't want to be
a jerk i want it to happen and you don't
want to be a jerk to him either i think
that that wouldn't matter they'll still
save your life but you don't want to be
a jerk to them
it's a communication is the best thing
that's that's the hard time i think
communication is the best thing i would
you know have an opportunity to get the
officer's badge number get communication
with the officers and set up a
contingency plan and say look this is
what we do here this is where i'm
located
you know if we have an incident can we
have a secret code where like if we call
something in we only we know a certain
past phrase i mean they just look it's
hard to get through the dispatch like
that but you but they could put
like because you're on our system and i
think the system is probably generally
the same across the board
your address has a flag on it right so
in the system it'll say that this house
was swatted they could write that down
in the system they could say this person
is a podcast or they can have a special
note for this address so therefore when
a call comes in to the dispatch the
dispatch runs the address and the
address has a flag on it and they go
okay they'll tell the officers this
person is a podcaster we've been there
before for swatting
you know here's this here's the person's
phone number so an officer can try to
contact a contact here first before they
show up and it becomes violent if they
contact the contact here you say no it's
real deal like we're we need your help
you know it's better to have
relationships with police than to
leave it up to chance because it could
go south and we don't want to be on
opposite thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you